Disney has officially announced that it
will be delaying the release of its much
mocked cartoonishly lib liveaction
remake of Snow White or sand beige as I
call it given the emphasis on diversity
casting I'm not saying that Jeremy
boring is single-handedly responsible
for Disney's delay I don't know that he
did it single-handedly but I'm quite
confident that if say seven hands were
involved at least six of them were
Jeremy
for a comparison here is Disney's new
Snow White you said you were bringing a
Modern Edge to it on stage what do you
mean by that I just mean that it's no
longer
1937 and we absolutely wrote a snow
white that is she's not going to be
saved by the prince she's not going to
be safe for The Prince and she's not
going to be dreaming about true love
she's dreaming about becoming the leader
she knows she can be sounds great here's
our Snow White by 2030 it's predicted
that 45% of women will be unmarried and
childless and why do you think that is
well it's because we've been told that
you know men are trash and that our
career is the only thing that matters
and that marriage and children will
inhibit that which is unnatural that is
biologically unnatural for women that
does sound great that's I mean what's
happening is really bad but the fact
that our Snow White realizes that that's
a problem and the girls actually do want
a prince and they do want like normal
stuff that's a good sign Disney is
obviously reacting to the Daily wire
announcement that we will be releasing
our version side by side with theirs and
Disney is also reacting to the terrible
reaction that their remake has been
getting among the public and then the
final nail in the coffin of this
remake's release came by way of South
Park just last week everyone I cared
about has been systematically replaced
and finally I want to scream and I'm
like why are they replacing every single
character with someone who is diverse
but then Kenny's like it's not our fault
it's cuz of Kathleen Kennedy but then
Kathleen Kennedy just like it make it my
name and everyone in town is like no
please cathine Kennedy stop ruining
everything but cathine Kennedy is all
like put another gay diverse woman in it
make it more lame and the Disney stock
just keeps going down and down and down
and the Bob is all like no it's going
my no make it more lame that is exactly
what they're doing and that is why we
hate the diversity equity and inclusion
casting and writing in movies we don't
hate it for the reason that the libs
think it's not that we conservatives or
forget conservatives that we normal
people are opposed to diversity exactly
what we oppose is
dishonesty the reason that we don't like
it when Hollywood replaces every white
guy with indigenous black lesbian
pygmies is that that is not how the
world really works in the real world not
every white man is an idiot or a villain
most white guys are actually pretty
decent fellas
in the real world not every woman or
person of color or other type of self-
styled grieved minority is perfect some
of them believe it or not actually have
complexity of character in the real
world not every single romantic couple
is interracial it happens I'm not
opposed to it when it does some of my
best friends are interracial couples but
it's rare I looked it up it's it's like
8% of marriages in movies and TV today
it's like
80% in the real world most people don't
consider themselves gay or in the real
world conservatives believe it or not
are not always ignorant stupid
malevolent Hicks sometimes those things
happen so it's fine to depict it
sometimes but the problem with the new
representation in Hollywood is that it
doesn't represent reality more often
than not it totally flips reality and
that is super dup
lame and so people tune the fantasists
out and they start to tune into
Alternatives right now go to preborn
docomo did you know that Margaret Sanger
the founder of Planned Parenthood was a
eugenicist well if not I would recommend
you look into her background when you
see the disproportionate number of
abortion clinics located in black
neighborhoods it says it all thankfully
pre-born exists to bring mothers and
babies together by providing free
ultrasounds and many other amazing
resources to expecting mothers all
services are free and assistance is
provided for up to 2 years pre-born is
truly life-changing but don't just take
my word for it listen to this powerful
testimonial I was sobbing it was a a cry
for prayer for God I'm so sorry please
so I got on the internet and I looked up
how can you stop an abortion from only
taking the first pill and I just started
seeing like abortion pill reverse is
this real and I found a hotline number
so I'm like if please God let me call
this number be real I called it and
somebody actually answered the phone
Miss I really need help um I mistakenly
took a pill and I'm so scared I don't
know what to do please I just was like
panicking they get me started
immediately on progesterone and told me
everything like it's going to be okay
when I came here out it was the my heart
was so warm somebody will go as hard as
if it was their children to make sure
your child is going to be alive and stay
safe so I really want it I want a lot of
people to know it's it's it's possible
you can save your baby you can reverse
that
abor pre-born needs us the pro-life
Community to stand up for the babies and
mothers who need our help one ultrasound
is just $28 and $140 will help Rescue
five babies pre-born has a 100% charity
rating so you can give with confidence
let's join together and help mothers in
crisis choose life just style pound 250
say the keyword baby that's pound 250
say baby or visit pre-born
docomo Le that is preborn
dcoms
kwes there is a poll that is surprising
some people but not me that shows that
gen Z the Zoomers want fewer sex scenes
in movies and TV what what's wrong with
these kids they don't want to see a
bunch of sex and stuff no they don't you
fdy duty kids you can just hear the
voice of Gen X and the Boomers and maybe
even the Millennials now you can hear
that voice of the perpetually cool you
know everyone from the Woodstock
generation down to my own generation
they say man you don't want to see sex
man sex is cool you guys are square why
what do you mean why don't you want to
see that I'll tell you exactly why so
this poll
finds that in a survey of 1500 students
almost half of Zoomers age 13 to 24 said
sex is not needed for most TV shows and
movies a significant amount of people
44% said that romance is over used as a
plot
device why is that well I'll give you a
related note from that same study and
that might explain what's going on
here in 2023 more participants in the
study wanted to see a white man as the
hero now it's different from last year
more participants in the study said they
wanted to see a black man as the hero in
movies and TV shows now they're saying
they want to see a white man as the hero
why what's going on do these kids hate
sex they hate romance they hate
black people or something no it gets to
exactly what we were talking about at
the top of the
show people are being deprived of an
important aspect of Reality by movies
and TV which are supposed to tell us
something about our
culture and because because they're
being deprived of that aspect of reality
they want more of it it's not that they
don't want relationships well Rel even
that term is so silly it's so clinical
it's not that they don't want love it's
not that they don't want romance it's
not even that they don't want sex but
they're inundated with it it's
everywhere everything is
sexualized there's ubiquitous porn
people dress like they're auditioning
for a strip club everywhere in public
and the even in the elementary schools
now you've got sexual indoctrination you
have actual pornography in elementary
school libraries now and being assigned
by
teachers so we got that that's taken
care of you know what we don't have in
this culture
any emphasis on friendship any emphasis
on any kind of nonsexual non-erotic
relationship and so the Zoomers who grew
up in this stupid culture come out and
they say yeah we'd like to see that how
about just like friendship what is what
is a friend people are so lonely they're
not lonely because there's any lack of a
hookup culture you it's easier to hook
up today than it ever has been but it's
very hard to make a friend that's why
they want to see that why do more study
participants want to see a white man as
the hero because now coming out of
Hollywood would you never see a white
guy as a hero the white guy's always the
bumbling idiot or the villain they
they've got they're only vicious and
persons of color are perfect and they
have no character flaws they have no
complexity of character whatsoever
coming out of Hollywood so when people
see that they say wait that's not really
how reality Works reality is I think a
little more complex than that and they
they desire something else this is the
great conservative constellation as I
pointed out before which is that reality
doesn't go away even when you live in a
highly ideological age reality is still
there and people at least occasionally
brush up with reality and they begin to
desire some connection between their
political order the entertainment the
laws the
everything and reality that's happening
again boy what a great clip that was huh
I know I agree I'm with you if you want
more great content you've got to ring
the bell subscribe to the Michaels
YouTube channel we'll see you next time